Okay, the correct answers are this one, this one,
and this one. The first is not valid because there's
a space in the name. The name needs to be
one string of characters followed by colon followed by space
and then the value. The second is correct. The
third is not correct because there's no colon. There needs
to be a colon between the name and the value.
This one is correct, User-Agent: ignore me I'm a spammer.
Now, the value, as we mentioned before, can have
anything you want in it. The final one is
also correct, i-made-this-up: whatever, is also correct. Obviously, very
few people use this header. You can make up all
the headers you want. And often, people do, you
know? If you, if you have machines talking to
other machines, they can respond differently to different headers.
And that's a good way of adding extra meta information
to the request